[Music]
with its outstanding movie score and
unique characters disney's moana became
a beloved disney animated movie in 2016.
after many years of rumors it's now time
to talk about a potential sequel in
today's original we speculate about the
possible plot of a sequel movie or a
series format of course not without
recalling the events of the first part
beforehand
the story revolves around 16 year old
moana who lives as the daughter of chief
tui on the paradisiac island of montanui
in the southern pacific together with
the other residents they worshiped te
fiti the goddess of nature who many
centuries ago was instrumental in
bringing third life to the surrounding
ocean for this purpose she used to so
called punamu stone the source of her
power unfortunately maui a demigod from
maori mythology is after the stone the
demigod of the wind and the sea is a
true master of shape-shifting and wants
to use the punamusto not for the
flourishing of the ocean but for the
creation of mankind in a fateful attack
by the volcano demon tikka maui loses
not only his giant fishhook but also the
stoneheart of the goddess of nature just
under a millennium later our eponymous
heroine moana is finally born when she
is 16 years old a terrible epidemic
ravages montanui which not only causes
the vegetation to wither but also
reduces the stock of all fish and sea
creatures to an alarming level through
her grandmother she sees some sailboats
equipped with a characteristic drums in
a hidden cave she also learns that her
people were traditionally voyagers
before maui stole the heart of te fiti
after that the sea was no longer safe as
the blessing of the punamu stone was
responsible for eliminating the dangers
of the high seas grandmother tala
finally gives her granddaughter the
fabled heart of te fiti and tells moana
on a deathbed that she must find maui in
order to restore defeat his heart moana
eventually embarks on a journey to track
down maui and convinces him to return to
fit his heart together what follows is a
journey of the two on the open sea until
they finally reach te fiti's island they
free the goddess who's trapped in the
form of the volcano monster tikka in the
end moana returns to her island where
the inhabitants welcome her joyfully and
finally go to sea again after a long
time
in addition to a possible sequel fans
are especially looking forward to this
series which has been announced at the
disney investors meeting in 2020 as
disney announced back in january this
will be available on the in-house
streaming service disney plus according
to collider the series will tie directly
into the events of the movie from 2016
however since it won't be released until
later in 2024 there's of course very
little information in the following we
speculate about what could happen in
moana 2 or the upcoming series and how
this story could continue at the end of
moana we see the villagers set sail
together and explore the newly opened
white ocean the inhabitants will
therefore very likely to find new
islands to populate under the guidance
of moana even though it has always been
her big dream to be on the high seas and
lead her sailboat sooner or later she
will have to settle down at the
beginning of the movie moana's father
prepares her for the future role as
chief at that time she was not quite
convinced of the idea as she always
wanted to sail out to sea despite her
father's warnings however after the fate
of the island has significantly changed
for the better one of the main themes
will surely be moana's new function as
chief of motonui certainly she has a
completely different style of leadership
and as already mentioned may rule over a
much larger empire than her father one
of her tasks could be to teach the
inhabitants and any newcomers the art of
sailing which has been in her blood for
many generations nevertheless we believe
that motanui stays as the most important
island in the moana series because it's
just too beautiful to look at also not
to be forgotten as a reunion of moana
and maui after the two had a somewhat
bumpy start they developed a friendship
in the end so it's a safe bet that we'll
see maui again in some form maybe they
will have to fight a big enemy again or
maui will even become a resident of
moana's home island montenui it could
also be that maui after years of
isolation finally explores the big wide
world and enjoys his newlywed freedom
either way we sure to see the two of
them in action once again the same goes
for the two sidekicks pua and haihai the
water loving house pig and the peculiar
rooster are sure to cause a few laughs
even though they do not play a leading
role in the story moana's grandma tala
who is one of the most endearing
characters of all will certainly be seen
in flashbacks after all she taught her
granddaughter many things and later even
appeared as a stingray her spirit gives
moana tips repeatedly and accompanies
her on her way similar to a guardian
angel through her one could also tell
more of the history of island nation
after all talon knows a lot about
pastimes the ocean will play another big
role as we can already see from moana's
childhood she has always had a very
special connection to the ocean and the
element of water in the end the ocean
even actively supports her which is why
we believe that the title character will
interact even more with the ocean
whether this can be compared to real
superpowers is left undecided but
there's still a lot of room for a story
an exciting question would be why did
the ocean choose moana as the chosen one
the final question is a crucial one who
will be the villain and the moana sequel
at the end of the movie it turned out
that the volcano monster tekka is just
the goddess defeated without a heart
this means there is no villain in the
story so far which is why there is an
urgent need to introduce an antagonist
the possibilities are endless we could
very well imagine an evil deity or an
antagonist to the demigod maui
theoretically the giant crab could also
be a big antagonist after all in a
post-credit scene we see him trying to
escape from his shell
in addition there are some other wild
and really creative theories out there
which would have strong implications for
moana too and therefore we present them
despite their abstruseness the best
known one says that moana is dead for
almost the whole first movie according
to that she died by the storm at the
beginning and is only revived by te fiti
and sent back to her home island alive
fans want to have found some evidence
for this for example that she doesn't
interact with normal people after the
storm passed also she experiences things
on her journey that a normal person
would never and she keeps meeting her
grandma tala and other ancestors before
she sees her as a stingray but doesn't
interact with her until after the storm
what impact this theory would have on a
sequel is of course difficult to
estimate but we didn't want to the
preview of this interesting train of
thought
now let's talk about the cast and
production of moana 2. it's pretty
likely that almost all characters and
the dubbing actress will return because
anything else would be a big letdown for
fans who else but wayne johnson should
voice the maui the demigod unfortunately
nothing is known about moana 2 yet but
as disney announced via twitter david g
derek jr the storyboard artist of
ancanto and moana will direct the
upcoming series for the first time we
can only hope that the animation style
and score will be as good as the
original fans of the moana series can
look forward to release in the course of
2024 a release window for the moana 2
movie is however not yet known
that's it again with our latest original
what do you think where exactly will the
series start and who could be the
villain we're also interested in whether
you would prefer to see the rest of the
moana story in a movie or a series
format after all both seem to play a
role at disney feel free to write us in
the comments see you next time
[Music]
you